Troy asks I work in two different spaces
how do I use social media platforms so
that I'm not confusing my
audience Troy this is a very simple
question uh you adjusted the platform at
hand so we're going very detailed on
this show for Twitter the way you don't
confuse them if you're talking about two
different things Allah business and wine
talk is you create two different
channels and you have an at Wine Library
account and you have an Gary vook
account Gary V and that's what I did or
you just become so branded in both that
you feel comfortable being kind of a
renaissance man or woman and you can go
that route but you have to react to the
platform so on Twitter you just create
two different accounts and you promote
through them on Facebook though the
targeting capabilities allows you to
just be yourself and talk to people that
act you can plan to people that are 25
to 45 that are into wine and you put out
a wine content and they'll like that and
you know 22 to 27 that are into podcasts
and you do that and then they want you
to talk about that thing so Facebook
gives you the flexibility to Target you
know Twitter does not uh and so you've
got to adjust YouTube channel do you
have two channels do you have one is
something we've talked about because we
want to chop up every answer into a
question as a matter of fact let's link
up the first one we put up right the
tennis thing over here uh and so uh you
know you're the real answer to this
question Troy is is you've got to adjust
to the platform's capability to drive
home the fragmentation or the one
channel process so you go PL place by
Place Pinterest you can create a board
right you can have an account you can
create different boards and on certain
boards you put out content about
whatever the hell you're doing and
whatever you're doing that's different
so you Tumblr you can create a bunch of
different kind of blah blah blah.
tumblr.com so that gives you flexibility
so I'm giving you very detailed answer
here my friend it's it's it's uh not
super hard you have to have the right
strategy per the platform based on the
flexibility of that platform to deliver
the story oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right Hooks and so
so subscribe